>>> Actor Danny Masterson, best
known for his role on "That '70s
show" was sentenced to 30 years
to life in prison for raping two
women in the early 2000s.
It was the maximum sentence the
court could give for the crimes.
More from CNN correspondent
Stephanie elam.
>> Reporter: Danny Masterson was
sentenced to 15 years for each
count of rape that he was found
guilty of in may, so that is
expected to be served
consecutively according to the
judge, so 30 years to life for
Masterson, and really a huge
part of this because of the two
named victims that came forward
and also spoke in court.
In fact, take a listen to the
assistant district attorney
speaking about this.
>> I'm very happy for the
victims because this is a day
they had been looking forward to
and justice was a long time
coming.
That's first and foremost.
But, also, being very thankful
for the jury to kind of see
through everything and recognize
what the evidence is and that
this defendant needed to be held
accountable.
>> Masterson had pled not guilty
to raping these women in his
home in incidents between 2001
and 2003.
His lawyer also spoke after
sentencing, and this is what she
had to say.
>> Mr. Masterson did not commit
the crimes for which he has been
convicted and we and the
appellate lawyers, who are the
best and the brightest in the
country, are confident that
these convictions will be
overturned.
>> Reporter: The assistant
district attorney Mueller did
say that they have no intention
of going back and reprosecuting
that third rape charge against
Masterson, which the jury was
deadlocked on.
He says they're satisfied with
these two counts and are moving
forward with that.
It's also worth noting that
Danny Masterson is a well-known
scientologist and the church of
scientology was invoked in this
trial, and what role they may
have played in this case.
However, we reached back out to
the church and they referred us
back to the statement thathey
originally sent out on may 31st
of this year, which says, in
part, there is not a scintilla
of evidence supporting the
scandalous allegations that the
church harassed the accusers.
Every single instance of
supposed harassment of the
church is false and has been
debunked.
Stephanie elam, CNN, los
Angeles.
>>> News of the allegations date
back to March 2017 when
journalist and former village
voice editor, Tony Ortega, wrote
on his site that Masterson was
being investigated by the los
Angeles police department, and
Tony Ortega is joining us right
now to discuss this.
So you've reported on this case
for years.
Your reaction to this sentence?
>> Well, it was a long time
coming for these women.
The reason why I broke that
story in 2017 was I found out
about the investigation and the
LAPD was handling it very badly,
and that these women were
panicked and they were afraid of
the church of scientology's
influence.
That's really been a big story
here, is how the church of
scientology protected Danny
Masterson for so long and
punished these women for coming
forward.
So that's the story I sent out
six years ago to see if these
women would ever actually get
their day in court.
Boy, they did.
They testified three times under
oath, they were cross-examined
each time.
But this week they got to speak
how they felt about things
without being questioned.
I think that was very important
for them.
>> And we saw in Stephanie
elam's report, she had a portion
of a statement from the church
of scientology, and here is a
little bit more from a statement
they had published on may 31,
that says there is not a
scintilla of evidence supporting
the scandalous allegations that
the church harassed the
accusers.
The church has no policy
prohibiting or discouraging
members from reporting criminal
conduct of anyone.
Scientologist or not to law
enforcement.
Quite the opposite.
Church policy explicitly demands
scientologists abide by all laws
of the land.
All allegations to the contrary
are totally false.
That a little more elaboration
on a statement coming from the
church of scientology.
When you first started to report
on this some six years ago, talk
to me about what kind of
obstacles you had in trying to
get information, versions of
events, et cetera.
>> Well, right off the bat, two
things.
The first thing they say,
there's no evidence about
harassment.
But they can say that now
because the civil lawsuit about
harassment hasn't progressed
enough to where they can bring
the evidence in.
I personally know about evidence
that showed the church of
scientology has tried to detail
this case and I expect it to
come out during the civil
lawsuit.
The second thing they talk about
is how there's no evidence of
scientology discouraging anyone
from going to police.
They say this day in and day
out, but during the case their
own written testimonies were put
into testimony showing that
that's exactly what
scientologists are told.
So you have their written
policies in court as testimony
saying that scientologists
cannot turn themselves in, and
then you have the spokesman
saying we don't do that.
It's just a lie.
Scientology lies, day in and day
out.
And that's what has made it so
difficult for these women to get
their day in court.
But like deputy Mueller said,
this court saw through this,
this judge educated herself
about scientology.
I'm sure that's what the
Masterson family will now focus
their appeals on, the ruling
about how much scientology she
allowed into the case.
>> And Masterson's defense
attorneys did tell reporters
they plan to appeal his
convictions.
Do you expect that they will be
successful?
>> Well, I know that they
believe they have a lot to
appeal on, because they will
complain about the judge's
rulings about how much
scientology to allow in, they're
going to complain about the fact
that there were a lot more
references to drugging in the
second trial than in the first
trial.
She also allowed in some
testimony about harassment.
I am positive all of those
things will come up on their
appeal and they will argue these
were mistakes by the judge.
The appeal will focus more on
the judge than on the victims.
And I'm told that when there's a
jury involved and the jury
believes this evidence, that
it's difficult for an appeals
court to overturn that.
But I'm sure the Masterson
family is hoping they find a
judge that will see it their
way.
>> Actors Ashton Kutcher and
mila Kunis were among dozens of
celebrities that wrote letters
in support of Masterson before
sentencing.
Was it at all impactful?
>> I don't think so.
I mean, the judge only had one
choice to make, whether to give
him 15 to life or 30 to life.
And based on the testimony and
the things sad said about
the severity of the crime, I
would have been shocked if she
had allowed him to have only 15
to life.
But this is just a standard
thing, the family and supporters
of the defendant will send in
letters to try to sway the
judge.
I got ahold of those letters
yesterday and published them,
and I think people were
absolutely shocked to see the
language in the letters from
people like Ashton Kutcher and